lari fari wäre ich dann wahrscheinlich
jetzt hier er ist willkommen beim neuen
video und zwar ich habe ja letztens
schon dieses format halt die erste folge
gab es davon schon viele von euch haben
es wahrscheinlich gesehen vielleicht der
ein oder andere auch nicht auf jeden
fall des annex privat da verantwortlich
so so mehr private fragen von mir ich
habe bock nur zweite folge zu drehen die
gibt's heute viel spaß wenn ihr
verkaufen dritten teil wie immer daumen
nach oben oder so und weitere fragen
stellt mich einfach unten in den
kommentaren wir vielleicht im nächsten
video und es los geht ja wir fangen erst
mal ganz locker spontan an und zwar um
die erste frage von lara huber und sie
fragen wie viele freuden hattest du
schon habe ich auch von 10.000 mal
gelesen die frage und ich bin 17
so wirklich freundin eine mehr nicht ist
ja auch eigentlich so weiß ich nicht
wenn ich jetzt schon fünf freundin
gehabt hätte man hätte ich da anfangen
soll ist auch scheiße wenn du freundes
für zwei monate und dann war's das
wieder oder nicht ja und das amt weiter
mit frage nummer zwei und zwar kommt die
von goethes faust was auch immer das für
name ist keine ahnung auf jeden fall
fragt er oder sie oder ist ich weiß es
nicht
wie stehst du zu der legalisierung von
cannabis ja ist ja zurzeit ein ziemlich
heißes thema würde ich mal sagen und
meine meinung ist dazu eigentlich wenn
alle kohle auch legal ist warum sollte
das dann nicht auch egal sein das ist
für mich ich mein alkohol bewegt doch
eigentlich viel schlimmere sachen
vielleicht die unbedingt von der sucht
er aber generell von alkohol werden
viele menschen an jesse von alkohol
werden ziemlich viele menschen irgendwo
überfahren von alkohol stürzten ziemlich
viele menschen irgendwo unter von
alkohol schlagen sich viele menschen von
alkohol und so weiter bei cannabis ich
bin mir zwar nicht so ganz sicher was da
für nebenwirkungen hat aber so will
morgens ohne dich von daher finde ich es
eigentlich logisch wer cannabis legal
und alkohol illegal oder nicht wenn ihr
bock habt schreibt eure meinung dazu in
die kommentare würde mich interessieren
weitergehende fragen nummer drei ja und
zwar kommen die von marie thesen und sie
fragen würdest du deine nächste
beziehung wieder öffentlich machen ich
habe dazu auf youtube lagen nächste sau
finsteren generell habe ich dazu nächste
sagt vielleicht hat sie einfach nur von
euch gelesen ich hab mal so ein
interview
für braunlage geben das ist ein juhu
magazin da ging es zum teil darum und da
habe ich ganz klar gesagt wenn ich eine
freundin hab ich werde vielleicht sagen
ich habe eine freundin aber ich mache
sich öffentlich weil es eigentlich
scheiß ist und so was gehört meiner
meinung nach natürlich man kann es im
internet zeigen machen auch viele habe
ich auch nichts gegen habe ich ja selber
auch gemacht aber es ist immer so eine
frage was gehört wirklich internet und
was gehört nicht ins internet ja die
nächste waage auch sehr interessant und
zwar so fragt wie hättest du eigentlich
geheißen wenn du ein mädchen geworden
dass er keine ahnung könnte man eben
meine mutter fragen wartet macht das
mache ich ja keine ahnung ob ist gehört
ab aber leider stellt euch mal vor ich
wäre lage worden dann hätte ich jetzt
hier auf youtube
laras beauty palace oder lara wie lara
klar ribery wird dann wahrscheinlich
jetzt sowie meiner mit frage 5 oder so
es war kommt liefern keine ahnung wer
sie es oder was auch immer hat
geschrieben schauen auch deine lehrer
deine videos also hab ich krieg so öfter
mal mit dass lehrer halt zu wissen dass
youtube videos machen und ich glaube da
gibt es auch den einen oder anderen der
deshalb schon mal gesehen hat aber das
ist auch nochmal eigentlich oder also
die lehrer die ich weiß ja nicht
bestimmt lässt dann die so hinter meinem
rücken so richtig darüber aber ist mir
nicht egal wenn du das siehst und mein
lehrer bist schöne grüße ja und dann
jetzt noch zu einer ganz wirklich
privaten frage die ich auch eigentlich
nicht beantwortet sondern singen und
zwar fragt sarah p 1999 sarah palin
steht wahrscheinlich findet nach mali
und zwar vielleicht sein vp 1990 kannst
du mal was singen wer lacht mich dann
mache ich das kein zweites mal wirklich
also mit solchen überhaupt singt wie
wäre es einfach mal hier diese boyfriend
von justin bieber kennt jeder passt
natürlich auch sehr gut zu mir glaube
ich dass kann ich auch gut in meiner
stimme rüberbringen was ihr boyfriend
never let you go away on fire is your
friend den text kann ich leider weiter
nicht leiter weiter nicht
kann man sich geben würde das war doch
gar nicht mal so schlecht oder wenn das
scheiße vatan schreibt in die kommentare
scheiße und wenn es gut war dann
schreibt ja das ist jetzt begriff dass
das will ich jetzt wenn ihr das gut von
den schreiben kommentare gut und wenn
jetzt schlecht fanden schreibt schlecht
ja leute so viel dazu erst mal wenn ihr
blick auf teil 3 habt dann weiß ich geb
den daumen nach oben habe ich eben schon
gesagt ansonsten weitere fragen und in
die kommentare rhein und in kubanischen
einwände hier oben links geht es weiter
mit der erstausgabe von check das auch
auf jeden fall für mich freuen uns nicht
sehen würde wenn wir uns nächsten montag
wieder vielleicht auch erst nächsten
dienstag das kann ich noch nicht genau
sagen ansonsten auf eine schöne woche
noch und